i am bringing the night pants nation
tour to minneapolis april 28th through
the 30th june 4th los angeles at the
world famous troubadour june 24th des
moines iowa one night only and june 25th
omaha nebraska one night only get your
tickets now
at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i want to say thank you as
i do every week for all your support
this
podcast continues to grow and grow for
the last four months our audio downloads
alone have been over a million so thank
you the youtube numbers are climbing
please subscribe it's a free thing to do
to help the show out and it really does
help the show out so
uh if you got to have more honeydew
man check out the patreon it's called
the honeydew with y'all it's five bucks
a month if you're in for a year you're
getting over a month free and you're
getting the honeydew a day early ad free
at no additional cost all right
we've got some of the wildest stories i
promise you in comedy you've ever
[ __ ] heard for five bucks it'll blow
your goddamn mind alright uh come out
see me on tour all tickets to all shows
are available at ryan sickler.com all
right now you guys know we do over here
we highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind
storytellers i'm very excited to have
today's guest back
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome greg fitzsimmons welcome
back to the honeydew greg ryan
to be asked back is always
really the pressure because the first
time in
you got that excitement you're a newbie
it's like being it's like being a virgin
yeah you know being a virgin that first
time
you know it's really special but the
second time
foreigner yeah double vision album
probably gonna get demonetized right out
of the gates
i had this thing where i do a podcast
called the sunday papers and we do our
fans we've been doing it for two years
every single week our one of our fans
writes and produces and records a theme
song for us that's different oh hell
yeah and we do it every week and then
some guy
took the songs he did for us and he
copyrighted them
and so every one of those episodes he
got paid for no because that's what
that's what youtube does if you use
somebody else's music all the revenue
that you made from your youtube clicks
goes to them so
we stopped doing the songs
mother i know
well i'll tell you what before we get
into what we're going to talk about
today plug promote everything everything
you'd like ready first of all thank you
for having me on thank you for coming
back dude um fits dog radio is my other
podcast and then sunday papers comes out
on sunday and then childish comes out on
wednesday and then i got tour dates
coming up la jolla
um
comedy store la jolla spokane comedy
club in april
then we got new orleans and lafayette
louisiana then we got plainville
massachusetts at some casino
denver comedy works at the end of april
and then we got
uh
irvine tacoma damn yeah it's a it's
crazy it's crazy uh baker's fields it's
all at fitsdog.com fytzdog.com
um i would i was just saying out loud so
i'm going to try to make this happen i
would love to perform in new orleans
where do you perform when you're there
it's my first time it's this place
called the howland wolf i think it's a i
think it's a rock club that they're
doing comedy yeah so i'm doing i'm
flying in
going in a day early because i haven't
spent much time in new orleans that's
such a great city and i'm gonna do that
and then um i think a bunch of my
friends are gonna fly down with me and
then and then we're gonna drive to
lafayette louisiana which is like in the
middle of yeah you know have you been
there no yeah i just know it's in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere
because i've driven from maryland to uh
new orleans and back so i've been how
you do the bum [ __ ] yeah wow all through
mississippi louisiana yeah let me know
how it is i really want to go i have no
idea how i would sell there or anything
but i just want to get down to new
orleans and tell some jokes oh hell yeah
there's no comedy clubs in new orleans
yeah there's not a comedy club there
never has been i mean is that right for
like a minute here and there comedy
clubs have popped up but there's never
been a substantial run of a comedy club
in new orleans so weird i mean it's kind
of like chicago was like that for a long
time there was no good stand-up and now
now you know zany was zany's was always
there but like but it was an impromptu
city then more than stand up yeah
yeah yeah there's a few cities that are
big that never had a big stand-up
presence
um
but
what do you think of la versus new york
comedy
well as far as stand-ups i think new
york owns la but as far as podcasting i
think la owns new york there you go
yeah i'll go with that i would say
that's fair yeah i mean the opportunity
to get on stage
in new york is there's so many more
chances and you know if you really
utilize it then you can see why those
guys are strong and good and funny and
it makes you funnier because when you're
watching a tell and samurail and colin
quinn and you know and then the big
names have come down it's just not even
the big names it's the guys that are
grinding it out joe list and mark norman
gillis all those guys martin norman and
christa stephanie [ __ ] kills big jay
dan soder those guys yeah so you better
step up your [ __ ] game
yeah
um i don't think there's that run of la
comics out here
i would say that that are
getting up as much as they are what do
we have out here unless you're on a
[ __ ]
mic circuit you got supernova yeah you
got
laugh factory
even the ice house is still closed yeah
you got the improv and you got the
comedy story and even they're not seven
nights right we're still behind the
whole you know you travel this place is
like a [ __ ]
goddamn time warp back here well what i
do because i'm usually gone on the
weekends on the road so i usually do
spots in town like on
wednesday thursday night so that way
since i'm only doing a couple
nights a week
and i live in venice i'll try to go out
and do three spots i'll try to do all
the clubs in one night and west side
comedies are great
i want to give them love they're yeah
yeah there's chris gorbachev yeah that's
a great club yeah yeah
um all right so let's let's get into
some of your uh trauma because i want to
hear about jesus i mean what a show i
know what a show and i love the laundry
list come on and tell us the worst parts
of your life yeah i'm watching
everybody's instagram and i'm tired of
seeing your best pictures yeah um
tell me about the the bu softball worlds
oh you know what i'm an idiot i am a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's softball i've been
the whole time
yes the whole time i was like what no
not only was it softball but at bu
because it was a city school we were
eagles the eagles boston no that's
boston college we're the terriers the
terriers but it was a d1 school but the
softball fields were so small
that we played with a 14-ounce ball it
was [ __ ] huge because the fences
weren't as far out
so it would have been a home-run derby
if they used regular-sized softballs so
anyway so
i grew up
not a great athlete i love sports i
would play any sport i had a brother who
is 13 months older than me so irish
twins competing playing
and uh but i was just never i whatever i
lacked the confidence to be a really
great athlete and i was [ __ ] tiny i
was skinny as hell i look like i just uh
i look like karen carpenter growing up
and uh
and i was just as emotional and i was
just as emotional as karen carpenter
[Laughter]
i wore flare denim and paisley shirts
and so
so i um
my father coached me in baseball and he
was my father was a six foot three guy
from the bronx and he was a [ __ ]
tough guy and he coached like a tough
guy was he harder on you because you
were his son oh yeah
oh yeah he used to bench me
he used to pull me
oh my god and then i lost my i lost my
mitt and so he made me play with the
catcher's mitt we had an extra catcher's
mitt and i was playing third base with
the [ __ ] catcher's man
and uh but like he just
he was like uh
yeah cigarette dangling out of his mouth
and he's talking about drinks and i'm
never coached like that today our coach
had a cigarette hanging in his mouth
while he leaned over your shoulder and
showed you how to bat and [ __ ] it would
be burning your eyes like god damn then
you're like do you have an erection this
is a weird coaching stance get behind
every kid
yep they're talking about smoking like
oh man but that's why bad news berries
was so great walter matthau was the with
the with the cooler full of beers at
every private movie it's it's a hundred
percent perfect i tell saguaro about
this all the time like we in life the
comedians we're the bad news bears we're
not supposed to win yeah we're not
supposed to win it's supposed to be
right there right and it's it ain't
happening right that's who we are we're
bad news [ __ ] bears yeah but don't
worry we're coming back next year yeah
yeah i love it that's a great movie it's
a great movie and uh and jesus christ
the language that those kids were using
yeah you can never do anything like that
trailer of the movie
used the n-word the trailer did the
trailer i remember the first came out i
remember on the language in it and this
the beard drinking tater marble goes oh
all we got on this team all we got in
this
this
yeah tea was a bunch of and then she
lists every bad racial epithet you could
say yeah which i don't say yeah
go watch the original yeah
so uh so he coached me and i was uh i
was nervous i was a nervous player and
that's no way to play b the worst thing
about baseball is you just hang it out
you're on a field you're relaxed there's
butterflies it's spring
your mind wanders and then in a
millisecond you have to be a
snap
superb
action shit's coming right [ __ ] right
and then turn around and throw it just
like i hated basil i'm so glad my son
didn't want to play baseball
uh and took up ballet instead
he gets a lot of [ __ ]
i didn't take a ballet i should have he
would thank me when he was older if i
pushed him into ballet right he would he
was like thank you
so uh
so anyway cut to college
and now i love intramural sports in
college because it's all the kids that
couldn't make real teams so the the bar
has been lowered
actually not as bad as i was before
and so i'm on this team and all my
friends in college i don't know why but
like this was my my senior year i had
four roommates one was the uh captain
lacrosse team one was captain of the
tennis team one was captain of the rugby
team
and then the other guy was also on
lacrosse and then me the cat and i was
doing stand-up comedy at this point
which is why i think they liked me and i
i got to be with the cool kids
so we had an intramural softball team
and they were [ __ ] good
and so they put me at catcher because in
softball the catcher does almost nothing
okay so let me ask you this this bigger
ball do you have a different glove or
does it still fit into a regular glove
same glove it is okay is it harder
though like the web and that it's a
bigger ball you said yeah you need a
decent size because you know there's
infielder gloves and outfielder gloves
yeah so you you need a outfielder glove
those are the bigger ones yeah and so uh
by but my glove because i didn't have
one is i brought my father's baseball
mitt to college and it was kind of like
sentimental had made me think about my
dad and it was it was it was big but it
was [ __ ] old it was like an old dried
out met and so but i'm playing catcher
so it doesn't really matter
and uh
so
we make it through the playoffs
there's 113 teams in the league damn
it's you that's 30 000 kids yeah that's
a lot 113 teams that's a lot we make it
to the world series we're in the finals
how many games do you remember how you
had to play through that it was like it
was gonna be right it was like two games
a week for
you know the whole the whole yeah what
is it a fall game or sprint a spring
game yeah so
we make it to the world series and uh
and we're playing great you know
john matarazzo who's who's who's on
varsity hockey
uh
is is a righty
but he can hit opposite field but he
doesn't show it he doesn't show it he he
hits him down the left side until until
he gets some guys on base and then he
goes opposite field so they he hits him
hard left they shift the outfield he
goes right down the right field line i
mean these guys are amazing and so then
uh what's your team name
do you remember i don't remember no
and then uh and i so so anyway we're we
are um
[Music]
we are
tied
bottom of the ninth
they're up
they got a man on second
guy gets up line drives to center field
guy from second rounds third
bill mountford's in center field gets
the ball throws a [ __ ] rope
rope i'm hoping it bounces before it
gets to me but no it's coming hot
i got my feet planted i'm in front of
the plate i'm ready to take the hit and
the ball comes in
and and i got him this guy's about
two-thirds of the way towards me and the
ball is right there i got him
we're going overtime
third two outs
ball comes in hits my father's dried out
old mitt
and the seam pops no and the fingers
open no and the ball goes right through
and the guy scores and they win the
world series
that's how they work that's how they won
and these guys had no mercy it wasn't
like it wasn't like hey fitzy you [ __ ]
up it was like fitzy you [ __ ] up they
were mad these are real athletes yeah
yeah and so
i so i was buying i had to buy beers all
night for everybody i just stood there
and i literally did have tears in my
eyes because it broke back so many
[ __ ] memories of
not being good enough for my father and
here it is his glove oh man that is real
yeah i i had so much insecurity about
sports too because i really
when you're when you're a boy so much of
how you define yourself is i guess it
depends on the boy but for me it was so
much about sports because my dad was
kind of athletic and you know i just oh
yeah my daughter's in softball now and
she's like i hate batting i go i know
you feel like everyone's watching you
and she's like yeah and i go look also i
don't know what the [ __ ] lee
we got her ass in but it's they're the
kids are pitching yeah all right and if
they're way too young to be pitching we
used to pass they they're seven yeah we
used to pitch in our little league kids
are throwing it over the back
forever so they do this thing where it's
four pitches and then the coach comes
out perfect
so um i told her i go don't swing
do not swing there's none of these kids
are throwing strikes just stand there i
go if one's crazy listen
little lesson don't play but no no i
teach her to have a good eye i know if
that thing's near you hit it but if not
if that thing's over your head or in the
dirt like she didn't even know i go you
don't she thought i had to swing no
matter what and try to hit that thing
i'm like no no no you got to try to hit
it if it's right in this strike zone
yeah and if it's not then wait for the
coach to come out and she has not got a
hit yet she keeps fouling them hard left
i'm like oh you're early she keeps
getting oh she's so close yeah uh but i
get it she's like i don't i don't like
that feeling i know it's all
i remember feeling like that my dad
would yell too and be like did he ever
coach you
yeah he would coach and help out and
[ __ ] tony was always harder on us too
and but he would tell us that later he's
like i'm harder on you because you're my
kid because i also have seen you do
better i know you can do better like
some of those kids can't do better yeah
my dad gave up on me he like and then i
played hockey like his glove did
and like his condom did because i was an
accidental bird
[Laughter]
but he gave up on me like i played high
school uh ice hockey and you did i did
but here's how bad i was i was good
enough to make the team every year i was
on jv freshman year jv sophomore year
jv junior year and then and then i think
this is against the rules i was on jv as
a senior were you really i was a captain
of the jv team when i was a senior but i
was funny that's why they kept me on
that's why the coach liked me because
like i used to give like we had these
morning meetings two days a week in
front of the whole school in the
auditorium and i would get up and i
would do
uh remember when joe piscopo used to do
the sports report on snl on a weekend
update i used to do it like that and i
would do these really funny reviews of
the games
and uh and so i cracked everybody up and
then you know and then i would
before before games we would all drink
we had uh if we had friday games we
would get out of school and then we'd go
drink and then we'd play it was fun we
just [ __ ] around
never came with my dad never came to a
game never came oh no no he came to one
game which one it was the one where um i
went to check a kid because the kid was
up against the glass and my dad was
standing right there and i'm like i'm
gonna line this [ __ ] up my dad's
gonna see the pain he's gonna see blood
splatter on that glass and he's gonna
accept me for the athlete that i am
so i go charging at the kid and then he
digs me out and i go flying into the
glass
and he can see the look of my eyes sorry
dad
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
oh my god
the shame
[Music]
and then my kid turns out to be a
[ __ ] star athlete really what sports
soccer he started soccer yeah well first
he did taekwondo as a kid and he got his
black belt when he was about 13 years
old and then he started playing soccer
when he was probably about maybe
nine
and this kid played club soccer and
school soccer so he was playing soccer
six days a week for ten years
and uh through all through high school
he was captain of his club team
his senior year he was captain of his
high school team and his club team both
teams went undefeated wow undefeated and
he was a star
and he could have played d1 soccer but
he was he thought about it he had people
looking at him and he was like no i want
to have a life in college
and i was like well
i don't know where you got it i don't
know where he got the talent from
that's badass yeah well position
midfielder man see those guys were yeah
i played soccer my whole life so i was
did you really oh yeah i was i was good
i i was all juko that's why i was joking
about all juke i was all juco and
community college what's juco junior
college that's all you know uh you see
it mostly with football but these juco
guys or the guys that like went to a d1
school they got in some kind of [ __ ]
trouble yeah they go to a junior college
to rebuild their character and
themselves and their stats and then they
go back to a different d1 school and
then into the nfl usually but um i was
all juco in college and then i played um
for the u.s when i was 16 i my brother
and i both went out for this um
it was like a u.s development team
um and we made that and i went and
played soccer in europe for so much most
kids
they backpack and do all that [ __ ] i
still got my month in europe but i went
playing soccer no yeah we made a team it
was it was an under 17 um teams usa like
olympic development squad or some
[ __ ] i mean i knew we weren't going
anywhere after that yeah but that's
amazing it was fun you just had a good
hard ass let me tell you something we
went i had a good tight ass you did we
went over there and we we [ __ ] we
were so cocky and arrogant just such 16
year old dicks yeah
and we go right down the field on their
freaking we scored like that and we
thought we were like whoa we are gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna run this [ __ ]
country yeah
greg fitzsimmons we didn't win a game
we didn't win we were there for a month
listen to me we played two three times a
day we didn't win a [ __ ] yeah we got
our asses it's a different sport over
there what i loved about it was the
physicality though that's the way i
wanted to play here they allow you to
play rougher over there
but man are they so much more advanced
this a friend of mine sam he said he was
talking to an english buddy of his and
he said the reason that he he coaches
soccer and the reason he thinks a lot of
americans suck at soccer is because we
force our kids right into competition
it's like my daughter she shouldn't be
playing softball right now she should be
learning skills so he said that's what
they do over there it's it's a couple of
years of skills and rules and things and
then they intermix games and fun [ __ ] in
there they don't go into competition and
recording stats and who wins and loses
until later okay and that's what he
believes separates the rest of the world
from us is that we're
getting there and
my daughter the guy's like the play's at
second i go do you know what that means
she goes no i don't know what the play
is at second means i go why would you
it's a foreign language
right you know dude king richard you see
that movie king richard
it's all about he keeps the daughters
out of the juniors and you know every
other
no pro tennis player had ever made it
before without having gone through the
junior system is that right and he said
[ __ ] that i want them to have a
childhood i want them to study i want
them to learn three languages and
they're not gonna and so
he uh he had
the best coach in the country
took the williams girls when they were
about 13
to florida in a training camp and then
they got there and he's like okay we got
we got tournaments coming up and the
father was like they're not going to
play any matches till they're
16 or something 17 so for three years
just skills just skills yup yeah that
makes sense
um
wow so you were good and and did you did
you did you meet any girls in europe or
it was just all yeah a couple girls
back listen this is 89
so man my father was pissed when i was
calling this girl from holland yeah he
was like what the hell that's a 40
dollar phone bill
did you show a picture of her and he's
like all right get on get on the block
she was a cute little blonde and then i
met a girl from new jersey named vanessa
and we kept in touch for a while she and
her friend would come down they were
jersey we were maryland so it wasn't
that far yeah we'd all hang out but
um man it was a [ __ ] we went to
holland germany
england we didn't go to london we went
to england
um belgium
scotland and there was one more country
we went to that say denmark damn
you went to denmark yeah we went over
there yeah and a kid on the team stole
the [ __ ] country's flag no [ __ ] we
were like are you [ __ ] nuts well
we're like imagine right now if we were
in the u.s and somebody [ __ ] stole an
american flag off a store yeah i was
like it
he folded up and set it over somewhere
we ran away i was like [ __ ] you i had
never shoplifted in my life i still have
never shoplifted in my life except the
last week in europe when we were all out
of money
we were [ __ ] dying and ditching
everywhere just hauling
right through the games we were running
through the middle of the [ __ ] games
to get away
it was bad it got bad it got bad yeah we
shoplifted like maniacs when i was a kid
that's all we did
um is your dad still alive no he died
when he was 52. fifty-two yeah what
happened young heart attack
at rayo's in harlem you know that that
restaurant and i love their sauce yeah
their sauce is great yeah so uh it's a
mob joint and uh i think we talked about
last time i was on the podcast we talked
about my dad dying but yeah so it's
weird because now i'm 55 and i've gone
past i am older now than my father ever
was that blow your mind it blows my mind
i say those exact words my dad died when
he was 42 i'm 49 now and it blows my
mind every day that i get up
and also i'm thinking i still think like
man i feel young
but 42 was seven years ago i felt even
younger then like yeah that's an early
[ __ ] time to go you probably look
better now than your dad did at 42 right
yeah guys aged more fast back then yeah
he definitely looked older i feel like
than 42. yeah um how did he die but he
had i had gray hair he didn't yeah brown
hair well it's interesting so originally
it was ruled a heart attack but then
right when i turned 42 which is [ __ ]
so crazy right when i turned 42 i
started having these crazy
like health problems i had just
um had kidney stones
and both of my legs clotted
so i think it's the kidney stones or
whatever and they can't figure it out
for like six months i'm going through
all these tests and everything and
um at the end of it they find out i have
this blood disease called factor five
lighting where i'm prone to clotting
okay
so they're like you need to get
um genetic testing you could die from
blood clots oh yeah oh i was it was bad
like it was they could not figure it out
and they would keep flushing me and [ __ ]
so i um they're like you have to get
genetic testing done because if one
parent has it it's not as bad as if both
parents have it so the thing is i'm
never gonna know
if my dad had it if my mom has it okay
right you know what i mean like i i
don't know how bad i'm gonna have it
so i gotta call my brothers and
everybody they all go get tested none of
them have it my mom my two brothers so
my dad had it and all these years later
the doctors tell me now like they also
said anytime in the 80s someone died
young they just called it a heart attack
and now you know 30 years [ __ ] of
technology and everything they're
realizing that a lot of these people
actually died of um
why can't i think of it now [ __ ]
clots yeah and he did have a little
blood on his lip and there was a little
on his toe so they don't know if he bit
his lip when he died or tongue or if he
actually had a clot so
i ended up having a clot i [ __ ] get
through it thank god and i found out i
have this so now
i just it's not it's nothing you could
like diet doesn't really help it or
anything it's a genetic thing and um i
gotta wear compression pants on planes
and [ __ ] and i gotta get up every
like i can feel my legs if i sit longer
than 90 minutes when i do it i feel it
and i hate to be like a backseat doctor
but like have you tried um gay
conversion therapy
gay conversion yeah i mean
this might be good for you i don't know
my [ __ ] blood clots
well like you know when they
when they came up with you know boner
pills they were originally meant for
something else and it turned out it
helped with that so just give it a shot
it was for um what was it so i think it
was like uh cholesterol
blood pressure or something [ __ ] right
and i think women had it too and they
gave they some study i read where like
the women gave it back and the guys did
not they're like what's going on there
i
which is the boner pills
and my friend's gay and he goes uh he
listens to the podcast he goes hey do
they they give you free samples for the
for the um blue chew and i was like yeah
they send me like cases on so much of it
he goes can i get some
i go wait let me get
so you're gay and you need boner pills i
go you ever think maybe you're not gay
maybe you just like nice haircuts and
show tunes like if it's if it's not
getting hard maybe you're not gay
he's like i'm [ __ ] gay
i'm just drunk most of the time
he sends me these videos he goes out on
sunday nights because sunday nights is
like the real gay party night
and he'll send me these videos of like
these bars and he walks in like
middle-aged guys with like bellies are
hanging from leather harnesses face down
and guys just come by and like slap
their asses and stick stuff in their
mouth and
you're not supposed to be filming that
[ __ ] but he's always like he's always
like discreetly shooting like the
darkest [ __ ] that happens man i went to
a club hollywood's a wild place when i
first moved here
i dated this girl from argentina i mean
this chick was
just you know they say whatever she was
definitely out of my league i was like
this this girl is doesn't know she has
no idea
and i mean just a bombshell and she was
[ __ ] she spoke
spanish you know just
everybody at work was like
there's no way she likes you i was like
yeah i'm with you yeah i'm with you all
right so one night she's like you want
to take ecstasy i'd never take an
ecstasy and she's like and we're going
to rent a limo and we're going to go out
and i was like okay
so we take ecstasy and she takes me to
this place on santa monica boulevard it
was one of those
it was a club depending on the night it
was a building basically a monday night
it was this and tuesday night but
saturday night it was a place called
cinematic s-i-n-matic
and in the front of the club was just
clubby dance whatever and she's holding
my hand and we're just [ __ ] zooming
and she's just walking me through this
club full of just hollywood freaks
dancing leather fishnet all this [ __ ] we
go to the back where there's a door we
go in shut the door and it's a [ __ ]
maybe 20 person live s m show nice and
i was just like
and i was and she's like do you like
what you see and i was like yeah yeah
and that was the night before father's
day and i i would like to look at the
camera now and apologize to her dad for
all the [ __ ] i did to his daughter today
before holiday
i'll tell you she didn't sleep i
promised you that she did not sleep
well so it was interactive
yeah you you could you didn't have to
you did i did not go up with no she and
i went home after that oh oh you got
inspired by it and then you went home
and you spanked her a little bit but it
was interactive if you wanted to come up
and respectfully do like there was a
girl up there with her nipples clamped
and you could go up and put [ __ ] on
people's bodies or you know uh they
would have um
[ __ ] like suspended from their like yeah
yeah [ __ ] suspended from their nipples
and they're [ __ ] whipping each other
whip somebody
yeah and she all she wore that night was
a fishnet outfit with pasties over her
titties and a g string that was her
outfit yeah i was like where are we
going and what were you wearing [ __ ]
jeans and like a t-shirt or something a
hoodie what i always wear say [ __ ]
and everybody just look at it's funny
because when you're with a woman like
that or a guy like that and they're so
good looking you know everyone's gonna
look yeah you know but it wasn't just
her getting the looks i was the
secondary looks i was getting like what
you you know whatever
you oh yeah yeah tonight yeah and all
they're thinking is this guy's packing
he's got something going on we don't
know about i did i had something going
on yeah when you push your body too hard
or you just feel run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated making
hydration a priority helps us feel
better on a day-to-day basis all right
liquid iv
it's the best guys i i take it every day
i'm if i'm feeling run down i throw a
liquid iv in some water and boom off you
go it's just a simple little pouch you
shake it up boom drop it in i promise
you you're good to go hydration is
everything all right and one stick of
liquid iv hydration multiplier and 16
ounces of water it hydrates faster and
more efficiently than water alone it
contains five essential vitamins it's
got b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks and it's made with premium
ingredients non-gmo and free from gluten
dairy and soy all right grab liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use code honeydew at checkout that's
25 off of anything you order there okay
when you use the promo code honeydew at
liquidive.com experience better
hydration today at liquidive.com promo
code honeydew saying goodbye to high
interest credit card debt is one of the
first steps towards financial
independence but the interest month
after month can feel like you're in a
never ending hamster wheel and that's
where upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom and a ton of you off
of this show all right so whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan and you can check your
rate in minutes for loans between a
thousand dollars to fifty thousand
dollars without impacting your credit
score you can even receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com honeydew that's
upstart.com
honeydew to check your rate today and
don't forget to use my url to let them
know i sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com honeydew now let's get back
to the duke i want to hear about this
assault
all right back to bu uh i went to uh i
went to college and um after
i didn't apply to bu i i was in europe i
took a year off after high school i
worked two jobs for like six months and
then i went to europe for six months
with a backpack on i saved three
thousand dollars and it lasted like six
months it did well it was like 1985. you
know but you actually were good about it
you didn't blow it well i bought a one i
bought a one-month url pass and then
some french guys showed me how to forge
it to change it to a six-month europe
house so buses and buses and trains were
free yeah
i was staying in youth hostels where it
was usually like ten dollars a night
and then once you're at the youth hostel
people tell you you know you get the
swiss guy that goes hey man you can get
falafels this place down on l street
they're two bucks and you know and then
people share food and it's just like
you're living cheap which is the best
way to travel yeah because you get to
know people and you count on people and
you kind of like you know and just
hooking up like having sex with i mean
it's just girls like you said we're good
hooked up with the hostels all the time
i went to the one in barcelona
i walk in
and i open the door for the uh for the
showers and i walk in and i see three
naked chicks and i i close the door i
walk out
and then as i'm walking away this girl
opens the door and she goes uh no no no
it is uh how you say co-educational and
i'm like
no it's not
when i'm walking and there's like you
know [ __ ] danish girls and like
african girls and everybody's
everybody's just embracing it and
everybody's naked and it wasn't like
stalls it was like a it was like a
holocaust shower it was a wide open room
with just spigots and people [ __ ] dry
in their asses and
oh my god i just want you to know you
just ruined that [ __ ] fantasy
for me
i saw the steam part ways and i saw the
corners of women over here
yeah there's nothing sexy about that
that's the least sexy shower scene in
history
not in psycho that is psycho right
and so
and i i i took a lot of [ __ ] i was there
for three days i took like three showers
a day man i was shriveled up i was i
would be too yeah holy [ __ ] i remember
when we were in um
belgium we were waiting um to get a
ferry to go back to i think it was it's
ferry ferry i know you're from baltimore
ferry yeah how do you say it it's fairy
f-e-r-r-y say ferris wheel
ferris wheel
what do you say ferrous yeah
[Laughter]
what do you call this part of your face
a forehead
what do you say far head i say i don't
know why i say forehead but i also
me and christian for some reason
both say uh what's the word we both say
wrong
um
maybe it's forehead
it's definitely forehead that's on the
list yeah
fairy
anyway i used to say sigourney weaver
did you realize that somebody's like
it's so gorgeous i was like but wait you
don't say journey you say journey yeah
oh nightmare
me and bird city yeah he said that on
here yeah it was a nightmare i don't
know why i say it that way
so anyway so i save up all this money
yes i go to europe i come back and while
i was gone i had no plans of going to
college i was a d student in high school
and uh so my father took it upon himself
to apply to boston university
and uh
and i get home and he goes
congratulations i said what he goes you
got into bu i go
i didn't apply to bu he goes
congratulations
and so i really he wrote the essay he
did it he wrote the essay about my trip
to europe based on the postcards i was
sending him from the road and so i get
in
and i show up to college and i'd never
been in the city before i literally
showed up my my mom brought me up my
first day of school
and like not a day early like did the no
the night before class was started i
show up
250 000 kids show up to boston for
college every fall that's insane yeah
250 000. so i show up and i'm like this
is [ __ ] heaven i mean boston's a
beautiful city you just see u-hauls with
hot chicks and denim shorts load loading
[ __ ] and i got i got my father's army uh
duffel bag that's all i got stuff that's
that's it
and i go into my dorm room
and uh
and i uh
i check in and i look at the door next
to me next to my dorm and it says chris
greenleaf and i go wow that's [ __ ]
weird because i grew up uh we lived in
cherry hill new jersey when i was like i
remember five and six years ago roughed
rough jersey was it back when we went
there oh i didn't know that
well i think we lived in the nice part
of the shitty town probably and so uh my
next door neighbor and best friend for
those two years was a kid of chris
greenleaf and he had jet blonde hair
and so i can just knock on the door door
opens kid with jet blond hair down here
he's a surfer i go chris greenlee if he
goes yeah i go
greg fitzsimmons he goes
get the [ __ ] out of here odds of that
so we start snorting crank that night we
stayed up all night snorting crying yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and and it was like the fun it was
and we just bonded first
first night we stayed up all night and
he knew this other kid from the other
dorm so we all hung out so anyway the
first week of school so like that
following weekend we were out
and i come back to the dorms and it's
like two o'clock in the morning and i'm
drunk
and as i come up the stairs i see this
girl
and she's being helped by two other
girls and she's crying hysterically and
i'm like what the [ __ ] happened
and they said she just got sexually
assaulted whoa and i was like
[ __ ] and i got a sister and i was like
my blood got boiling and i was with
another guy named jeff jeff brown
and we go what did he look like where is
he and they said he's got on a just just
say like mississippi prep school he had
something very specific on his
sweatshirt
his blue sweatshirt big guy and i said
all right let's go let's go find him so
we uh so me and jeff split up bu is
basically one avenue it's one avenue in
boston and so he goes left and i go
right and i go running up the street and
i see a kid in a sweatshirt
it says mississippi prep school on and i
go hey i go they want to talk to you
back at the dorm
and he's like what are you talking about
i go you just molested someone you're
coming back to the dorm so the guy
pushes me he's with another guy and
they're [ __ ] huge it turns out later
they're on the football team
so i'm on the ground i pick up a very
fine fruit punch bottle and i smash it
and i chase after them and they run into
the dorms but the dorm that they're
running into is like it's got a the you
have to be buzzed in by the security
guard and the security guard is behind
plexiglas
and so i enter as they enter and they're
showing their ids and i go don't let
them in i go this guy just attacked
somebody at the dorm call campus
security call the police and the guy
comes at me and i'm holding the [ __ ]
bot and i'm drunk and i'm i'm a [ __ ]
lunatic but i got the bottle up and i
got i'm holding two football players
with a very fine fruit spot they call
the cops and it takes it takes a while
they're like trying to negotiate
they're coming at me i'm going like that
and so the cops show
up the cops show up and they look at me
like who is this lunatic i go this guy
so anyway they they get them they get
their statements
they get their id
blah blah blah
turns out the girl who it happened to
carol
she decided she was a freshman first
week of school she didn't want to press
charges
she wanted to just go away she want to
enjoy your freshman year and not deal
with it
which whatever
so then
i get charges pressed against me for
assault with the deadly weapon by the
two guys fine juicy bottle kid that
gives a very fine juice bottle so i get
a letter sent to get them to sponsor
your podcast dude
very fine when you're in a pinch
two guys bigger than you
now when you got very fine that is great
and so they're pressing charges so
they're pressing charges my parents get
a letter from the dean of the school and
from the head of the dorm saying i'm
losing my campus housing i'm getting
thrown out of campus housing
and i might be thrown out of school and
they have a hearing and so and what are
the charges like what are you facing is
it real jail time or is this just a
college assault with a deadly weapon
it's real [ __ ] yeah so what are your
what are you facing like how many years
did you get for this [ __ ] i don't know
but but i know that at the preliminary
hearing carol showed up
and she sat there and she said
if they don't if they don't and i talked
to her about it i said if
she said if they don't drop the charges
against him i'm pressing charges for
assault
and they drop the charges
and uh she let it all go and i became
good friends with her that's nice in
college yeah good for character first
week yeah what a traumatic experience
and then for her to have to go in there
and and put herself on the [ __ ] line
i know she's deaf for me yeah that's
nice yeah and your friend your friend
lee with her or became friends yeah and
then jeff brown the other guy who i'm
still in touch with to this day and i
had met him that night and we kind of
bonded over it though do crank with him
too
like come on girl i got the answer
i guess i should have said the other
kid's name i'm talking about doing crank
but whatever
i mean
um
okay i want to hear about this cause we
you and i share a common friend vicky um
and i met her at oprah
vicki ernst yep and she met you at ellen
yeah
right and i met her at oprah and right
away i know you when you meet her you
just she's one of those you just click
with right away you're like of course of
course you like her she lived with us oh
really we have we have a little uh
studio apartment in our guest house in
the back and she lived there for like
two years she's the best she's the
greatest i mean i could sit and talk
sports with her like but really talk
sports yeah i just covered two dd's
[ __ ] are running i was like
that's awesome okay so you worked at
ellen and you know we hear all these
[ __ ] stories about how horrible and
everything what do you what what can you
tell us
cause it's on your list so obviously
it's a low light some of it i have to
dance around certain things because i am
under a non-disclosure agreement but i
mean i think there's certain things that
i can talk about because they're not
defamatory to the show
but which i would never be
so
i get i get hired at the show as as a
writer and and you know and you gotta
remember something like ellen degeneres
is one of the best comics to ever do it
yeah and i was a huge fan of hers when
she was just a road comic and then half
hour vh1's half hour comedy hour i
remember seeing her doing the smoking
yeah yeah killing it killing it
killing it killing it and i was like so
i heard that she was i talked to karen
kilgariff who was uh yeah she was hired
as the head writer for the show one of
my faves and so karen tells me about the
job can i ask you did you have to submit
a packet or what did you have to submit
for a show like ellen and was our was
ellen already going when you did or was
this a new thing coming they just
developed it and i was i was brought on
for like three months before it started
to help come up with what the show would
be
and uh but no i i think uh the the
executive producer mary connelly i knew
because she had booked me on letterman
she booked me on killborn she used to be
a
an executive producer on other late
night talk shows so she so i knew her so
i was in there and then karen obviously
we were good friends and she was the one
who suggested i go for the job
and so
i think i did write so yeah i did i
wrote some monologue jokes for her and
she responded to them and so i got hired
so i come in
i'm a writer producer
and then we're doing test shows so we
bring in audiences you know before the
air date to to try out segments and
try some models with ellen with ellen
okay we did test shows
and so at the time we were look they
were looking for an audience warm-up
person and they couldn't find anybody
that ellen liked you should look at
stacks of tapes of guys that were the
best
i don't like him i don't like him so
then during the test shows they ellen
said greg warm up the audience so i went
out
i just did my stand-up and uh and i did
some crowd work whatever
and so as we get closer to the start
date the executive producer comes to my
office and and she goes uh ellen ellen
wants you to be the warm-up guy and i go
i'm not doing
[ __ ] warm-up on a daytime talk show
plus writing and producing right which
is my main job and she goes well here's
what it pays and it was like significant
money it was extra on top of my salary i
was going to get a whole other salary
for literally
walking out for five minutes all you got
to do five minutes do a little stand up
bring her out and you're you're done oh
you're not coming out the whole during
the commercials they just played music
and the audience would dance because
everybody loved it yes right
so it was the easiest job in the world
for a ton of money and so i was like all
right i'll do it i'll do it so i go out
there and real quick is this was five
days a week
we taped five shows and five shows in
four days
fridays was a production day
and so the first week i go out there
and uh and i it's
easy it's basically warmed down because
her fans are so insane yeah you gotta go
hey everybody
keep [ __ ] together okay she's just a
person
relax yeah it's like that instead of
when normally you're going like come on
everybody get up on your feet yeah it's
the easiest job in the world and i would
crush i would do my i would do my like
you know clean as jokes i would crush
and then i would uh and then i would sit
in the front row and i had cue cards and
i had a magic marker and i would i would
on the fly i would write jokes for her
and i'd hold them up and she'd do them
and so it was fun
and uh but the first week um i went out
and i said to the crowd and i'm trying
to figure out what warm-up is what else
what else can i never done that i've
never done anything and i go i go all
right you guys let's do let's do the
wave you guys want to do the wave
i said yeah all right i said okay
whenever i say banana you guys do the
wave
and so i i start talking i go banana and
they do the wave and and meanwhile i'm
friends with eric lederman and a bunch
of guys that are standing on the side of
stage doubled over at what a corny hack
i am and so so anyways the show starts
ellen comes out to do the monologue i'm
sitting in the front row and i'm sitting
like not like 15 feet from her right in
front of her
and she comes out and she starts the
monologue and then she goes uh so i made
a smoothie and i put a banana in
and i completely forgot that we had the
word banana in the monologue yeah
how did they do it the crowd stood up
and did the wave
this is the first week of the show ellen
is still nervous she hasn't and i'll
send you the way she goes like whoa she
goes what just happened what just
happened i go you guys just did the wave
that's that's funny that's weird why'd
you do the wave okay
anyway so i made a smoothie
and uh so i peeled a banana
they do the way
she goes okay i don't know what's going
on but if you guys could stop doing the
wave and i'm sitting there going like
holy [ __ ] does the entire audience think
this is a bit at this point no they're
in on it they think alan's in on it they
think that this is all the plan the
warm-up guys set up ellen so that she
could do this
and so it happens one more time and then
she just goes all right stop stop taping
stop the show what's going and so i have
to go up on stage and go ellen i i kind
of [ __ ] up and i told him to do the
wave and uh
she was not happy she's not happy yeah
i would have laughed at that though i'd
have been like for real you [ __ ] did
this
i think if
it happened maybe a month into the show
but it was like the first week
and uh yeah and that's okay so i got i
got to my desk the next morning i showed
up for work and there was a pile of
bananas my friends
but uh
no but i can't speak about those days as
much as i'd like to
i try to try to not get sued yeah how
long were you there
i was there the first two years two
years won four emmys did you congrats
two for producing a two for writing hell
yeah yeah how's that helped in your
career has it helped
i think a daytime emmy i think four of
them equals half of a nighttime average
a lot
nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody cares nobody
cares no that's cool you got a trophy
yeah and they look good i gave my mom
one and she loves it
and then the other ones are like tucked
away in my office
yeah i got the youtube plaque on our
wall over here nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody cares about this what's the
youtube play when you hit 100 000
subscribers they send you a play yeah
and then the next one's at a million
they send you another player oh [ __ ] or
maybe there's a half a million i'm not
sure but yeah they send you a plaque
that you pay for yeah you know nothing's
free dude yeah yeah yeah all the money
all the money they made off you and
they're like you gotta pay for that
right
right
yeah those that hardware is nice though
when you get older that's what i'm
saying
um
what's some of your go back to uh some
of the jobs yeah before comedy was some
of the worst [ __ ] you ever did
i did it we had a uh me and my brother
started a business we lived in newport
rhode island ever been in newport i've
been no i've been to rhode island yeah
newport is a
fancy ass town it's all the biggest
matches they were all built during the
gilded age you know like the the asters
and they had all these like literally
they look like museums they're gigantic
and they're on the most breathtaking
stretch of of rocky coast
and it's amazing and so we go out there
me and my brother are going out there
and we're living in a house with 11
other people it's a converted horse barn
are you family or is this all friends or
it's just me and my brother and then my
buddy chris and then a couple friends
from college and then a couple of their
friends and god
so so we're staying in this house and me
and my brother decide because we we had
met a guy we lived in the hamptons the
summer before
and we were busting tables and [ __ ]
never been there either i really want to
go yeah hamptons is nice
and so we go out and uh and we knew this
guy and he was running his own business
and so he we learned from him we just
basically talked to him a lot we go
we're gonna do that next summer and so
the business model is
you go to all the real estate places
and you say we are going to do
any odd job
anybody needs done
landscaping babysitting house cleaning
ride to the airport [ __ ]
driveway ceiling whatever you need done
pool cleaning we do it
we don't do any of it but we tell them
me and my brothers show up we put on
suit and tie and we walk into every real
estate place in newport we got these
nice colored brochures we made up and we
hand them out and everybody's very
impressed and and it's also one of those
places where it's so expensive to live
there that it's actually hard to find
people to do menial jobs yeah and i know
that people with money love to pay for
[ __ ] that's convenient right right save
them their time is valuable exactly
so
we start our start phone starts ringing
off the hook and we're getting jobs and
we've we've got everybody in the house
that's a great idea they're all working
for us and the idea is we're charging 20
bucks an hour and we're gonna pay our
friends 15 bucks an hour and we're going
to keep the five and just answer phones
all day and so
we start sending them out and of course
they're all [ __ ] hungover people are
showing up late people don't want to die
i'm not mowing along would i we
yeah you said you're drunk and i'm not
about 15 why are you getting 20 and i'm
getting 15. well because we were the
ones that said that that's not fair i
should get 20. well then what how are
you getting like all of that all day and
it turns into me and my brother doing
the jobs it turns into just us you did
do it we did all the [ __ ] and we didn't
have no idea we're doing this one guy mr
schindlerman he owned a condo complex
and it was like a bunch of little
bungalows around a swimming pool
and he charged premium money because
there was a pool
so he hired my brother to open up the
pool and when you i don't know if you
know about pool maintenance but you got
a shot shock
guard yeah and the ph everything's got
to be balanced yeah and and and we show
up and there's algae on the on the pool
and the and the the the pump doesn't
work and everything's [ __ ] up so my
brother said i can take care of it and
we're charging them and my brother like
can't figure it out the first week can't
figure it out the second week memorial
day comes and goes the tenants are
complaining by july the pool still has
algae on it there's a rent strike
because
gentleman
been paying us so now we've got a
lawsuit we're dodging this guy i do a
driveway ceiling job which i don't know
if you've sealed a driveway but you get
this like tar and you and you pour so we
went to this hardware store
and we bought some some of the tar
and uh and i i didn't read the
directions i just i just got a broom and
i [ __ ] swept
made it black
i leave i get paid
two days later it rains
and i was supposed to something i didn't
do right the rain washed all the guitar
into this like ten thousand dollar
japanese garden killed all the flowers
yeah destroyed the driveway looked like
[ __ ] she's suing us
and then meanwhile
yeah meanwhile like there's this one
girl we got this other woman and we're
cleaning our house and she's she's a
divorcee and she's newly divorced and
she's got this apartment and she wants
us to clean it and so me and my brother
don't want to clean it so we say all
right we'll switch every other week each
guy will clean the apartment
and i would show up
and i'd be like man this woman's a
[ __ ] pig this place looks like it
hasn't been clean in two weeks and so i
started going like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then i find out my
brother's showing up and he's banging
her and he's not cleaning
he's just having sex he's getting paid
he's getting paid
and i'm doing two weeks worth of
cleaning
and i'm flirting with her i had no idea
so i'm kind of flirting with her but i
didn't he he did she know you were
brothers oh yeah oh she did oh yeah yeah
yeah but he had game i didn't have the
game that is hilarious and so so we had
a 76 ferrari station wagon plymouth
velara yeah
and the uh it didn't
somehow it didn't
reverse didn't work
and so whenever we parked the car we
would have to open up the doors me him
and my friend and we would just kick we
would kick it backwards to get out of
parking spots yeah and so we left your
flintstones
[Laughter]
and the company was called
sure thing home services
hlr push it out of a parking space a
short thing over here
picking up girls all right ladies open
your door
you got to earn this one high heels
so we left town and like uh by at the
end of the summer we packed our [ __ ] and
we left in the middle of the night
and no lawsuits ever hit you no shit's
ever followed we went back to college we
forgot about it dude that is [ __ ] a
10 000 japanese garden like it had to be
the worst [ __ ]
toxic whatever i used was toxic
what was your very first job ever
i used to caddy
when i was like i was probably like 12
and and i would uh
i weighed like
less than 100 pounds and i go out there
they give me one bag but this is this is
in the 80s when people had those rodney
dangerfield bags
[Music]
but these guys would [ __ ] they'd have
an umbrella they would have like 30
extra balls
they had like weight you're supposed to
have 14 clubs he's got to have like 17
clubs in there a rain jacket an extra
pair of shoes and and the golf course
that i worked at
it was like the hilliest [ __ ] it was
and if you if i looked it up online the
average golf course if you walk it is
about seven miles
so i'd be out there golf
golf yeah say like baltimore right i
said golf oh you say golf yeah like the
gulf of mexico you say golf of mexico
gulf of mexico so you say say it again
well gulf of mexico spread spell g-u-l
yeah i say it the same way as what i'm
saying yeah really yeah golf and golf
gulf of mexico i'm gonna go golf
i don't change it
so sorry so
and i worked my way up to two bags and i
used to get i can't believe this [ __ ] i
used to get up
at like
6 30 in the morning i'd get on my
10-speed bike and it was about a seven
mile ride to the golf course one way one
way was seven miles i'd get there
i would carry a bag and then eventually
two bags for seven [ __ ] miles some
days i would do two loops
and then i get back on that bike and i'd
ride it back home again all right and
then i got this math in my head if you
did two loops that would be 14 miles 14
miles would be that's a seven ride and
seven bucks so 28 miles yep holy [ __ ]
yeah
and hilly bam yeah yeah yeah and you're
biking and walking yeah
[ __ ] and then i go drinking all night
well you're probably in the best shape
of your life isn't it amazing when you
were young the energy that you had
i could go out i could sleep you know
five hours and go do it again i don't
want to do that with a cart
right you know what i mean i didn't want
to drive with it yeah and we would go
and on the i'd ride my bike and i'd stop
at twin donuts on the way and i get a
ham and egg sandwich on a roll and all
the cat caddies would sit in the yard
and they bust each other there's all
these kids from yonkers he's like tough
irish catholic kids from yonkers and
they were the funniest [ __ ]
i've ever met and it was this one kid
his name was bob kolacki and they called
him killer kalacki because he had his
head shaved and he was trying to get in
the marines
but he kept getting rejected because he
was too intense he was too intense for
the marines
i've never heard of that in my life yeah
yeah this guy would be like climbing
[ __ ] trees while he was out there and
they there was i think he had a record i
think he had some kind of a record
and uh and there was another guy named
one arm willie who was a one-armed caddy
who was the one-armed caddy yeah and he
was pretty he looked like he was in his
80s he was old they'd sent him out with
one bag one arm but they but the members
loved him because he could read putts
and he knew the course
um pga jack there was a rumor that he he
lived in his car and there was rumors
that he'd killed people
and he lived in the [ __ ] parking lot
of the country club he slept in
his car
[Laughter]
smelled like [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah
and and then the the caddy master bobby
bobby ormond
he would do this thing when the fall
came and you were caddying in the fall
he had uh the bedding slips for the nfl
and so if you if you bought a ticket
then you got a good loot if you if you
bought five tickets you got a really
good loot if you didn't buy any tickets
you didn't get out that yeah
at all yeah oh he wouldn't even say yeah
yeah there was a lot of ass kissing that
went on there was a lot of politics that
went on
this is great dude i look we are there
already i can't believe we're there
already we got to get you out of here uh
i got to get out of here but thank you
for doing this this is a pleasure man
anytime brother and it's good seeing
around the store now i'm so
congratulations on passing in thank you
doing some stuff everybody's been super
uh
um kind about i'm very i was pleasantly
surprised by that
well it's mostly people just don't give
a [ __ ] but somebody it's it's a
different camaraderie there no it's a
club i mean it's a club and you're in it
and you should have been in it a long
time ago but but the the truth is like
when guys like you were working the club
it's better for everybody you know
because the lineups are stronger and the
crowds get hotter and you know it's
great yeah it's been coming back it
feels good in there lately yeah
um plug everything again please all
right i'm going to be on the road go to
fitsdog.com to get tickets i'm going to
be coming to uh uh
where am i la jolla
and
spokane
and
new orleans lafayette
denver comedy works my second favorite
club in the country what's your first i
never say all right tell me later i
never say because if i say tacoma if i
say then people the other club owners
like hey what the [ __ ] right
yeah
but this is my second favorite podcast
[Laughter]
i'll take it brother i'll take it
as always ryan sickler.com ryan sickle
on all social media we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you